i don't know
i don't think i've ever been this
mistreated in my entire life we get a
call
from uh our owner of the organization
eric
and he's just like yeah stop playing
like there's no knees
you guys are not going to play for a
second when standing in the u.s i
definitely tried to consider my options
now you can be very behind them they're
going up hey and katie if that smoke
arrives i think they're going to
disrespect it
he's got a good chance at another here
canadians on for
he takes over the game they are the real
deal they have shown some incredible
counter strike i am blown away by how
good they are
that was dorwan from snatching but down
oh my god the 3k setup looks strong
katie with the first kill look for a
second quick scope lance
and kadian keeps going three kills on
the hold
cat nico with the kill katie and snipes
apex
and then he follows into siwu no way
best player
in the world cause canadians 28-3
i played for so many years without
winning anything and finally it's paying
off so thank you for sticking through
with me
and thank you for giving so much i'll
try to give it back
right now cadian is one of cs go's
biggest success stories
he's the igl for heroic a team that held
the top spot in the hltv rankings back
in october
and for good reason they've been a
menace in cs go winning huge tournaments
that have inspired equally
massive celebrations from their leader
unlike his teammates kadeen's cs go
career is anything but young he's a
grizzled veteran who's been grinding his
way through the professional scene since
2013.
during the early part of his career
kadian found himself bouncing from
roster to roster
although it wasn't always his decision
sometimes it was caused by his bad
attitude
which he admitted in an interview with
hltv by 2015
kadyan had become something of a
wandering mercenary jumping from roster
to roster
finding little success but thanks to his
enthusiasm and understanding of
counter-strike
opportunities began to present
themselves outside of the game which is
something he told content creator paola
about
well we got our ass kicked at the esl
katsuwicz 2014 while i was playing with
mouseboards
and we went outside and everyone was
like on tilt
and pansy came over like oh guys i hope
you're okay sad to see that you're out
this early and stuff
and then we just talked about the game
and she was like okay this guy could be
interesting and she asked me to come and
do some of the analysis at that event
and like they liked what i did so i got
like the entire event and as kadian
struggled to find success on the server
his star began to fade
further and further into obscurity we
had juliano there
and she was uh representing team secret
at the time she had a
at this point uh well not fable fables
wrong word um
historic match in a sense against
canadian yeah kady and um
who's getting playing for now i'm not
entitled i think his story
uh tells exactly what he's playing for
now but these last few years have seen
cadian's career do a complete
180 and that kicked off when he joined
rogue as a last minute addition in the
latter half of 2017.
rogue presented a unique opportunity for
cadian not only would he be playing
alongside new teammates but because the
team was now based in north america
he had a shot at rebuilding his career
in a new region
although the move required him to leave
his friends and family behind in europe
it was a sacrifice he was willing to
make and sure enough
it was a sacrifice that paid off rogue
exceeded expectations qualifying for the
2018 london face-it major
after four years kadyan was heading back
to cs go's biggest stage
although rogue's run at the major was
disappointing cadian's performances
earned him a roster spot on north which
allowed him to return home to denmark
but as cadian recently revealed to hltv
that dream offer turned out to be a
nightmare
to be honest i think it's one of the
worst teams i've ever played in
uh straight up i remember three months
in or something
um we were playing average we were still
sub 10. i remember i was just
considering going to the sports director
and say
yo listen if you can trade me to uptick
or
sell me or something like i'm honestly
down and i didn't do it because i wanted
to try and fight for it but
that kind of mentality of not wanting to
go the extra mile to
to achieve greatness that just has such
an
insane effect on the team i'm so happy i
got out of that team honestly
yeah just six months into his stint with
north and cadian found himself sitting
on the bench
but it was during that time that he was
approached with an opportunity
to play with another danish lineup
although cadian was initially brought in
to play as a stand-in for blame
f his performances actually earned him a
starting spot on heroic's roster
there's no way around it we had a really
good synergy
doing those games had a lot of fun
outside playing as well which i think is
important for the team chemistry
but we just clicked from the very first
map so
i think that could be a good indication
of of potentially playing for rock at
some point and moving into 2020 the new
year looked bright for cadian
heroic was performing well and the team
was headed to la to compete in
flashpoint
on top of that the roster was about to
be picked up by funplus phoenix
who had just recently conquered league
of legends but right as everything was
looking up
once again kadian found himself staring
down the face of misfortune
see right as all of this acquisition
talk with fun plus phoenix was taking
place
heroic star player patrick acetag hansen
was scooped up by astralis and that
departure
caused the entire fpx deal to fall apart
and the most messed up part about this
deal falling through
is the fact that it left kadyan and the
rest of the heroic roster
stranded in los angeles in the middle of
a global pandemic
i still remember just setting up to play
the second game a flashpoint and then
we get a call from our owner
of the organization eric and he's just
like yeah
stop playing like there's no knees you
guys are not gonna play
uh yeah let's pack my [ __ ] uh let the
four
five other guys take a taxi back to
the apartment we went and i was just
walking there solo
just thinking my life i just crossed the
globe
in the middle of the epidemic and i
don't even get to do what i did
for for for leaving for that place so
there cadian was
stranded in los angeles without a spot
in flashpoint
during the middle of a global crisis
unsure about his
and his team's future it was at that
point his lowest point
that he turned to the community for help
hey everyone wanted to share a quick
update on the situation
we as fpx
heroic call us whatever name you want
will not be
finishing the first group stage of
flashband
probably just won't be playing the
tournament though let's be real i'm so
gutted honestly like the sacrifice is
being made
to family and friends to try and be the
best you can in
in a video game and then at the end of
the day you're not allowed to play this
video game
i don't know and while cadian was
obviously down
he definitely wasn't out
having lost essetag and snappy heroic
were forced to regroup and rebuild
and so they recruited tesses from the
copenhagen flames and optic gaming's
nico
now initially the results for this new
look heroic were not anything to write
home about
but things began to change as esl one
cologne rolled around
now he can be very quick behind them
they're going up hey and katie if that
smoke arrives i think they're going to
disrespect it
he's got a good chance at another here
canadians on for four
maybe even the eighth go on canadian he
takes over the game
heroic made it to the finals of one of
the biggest and most prestigious
tournaments of the year
and their path getting there wasn't easy
beating phase
g2 and complexity you're in the grand
finals of esl one cologne
like yeah disbelief honestly
unbelievable yeah disbelieve for sure
i mean in a way because you've worked
hard for this the way we've been playing
yeah i mean the way we've been playing
in that sense it doesn't come as a
surprise
but i think if you asked anyone like one
month two months ago would it work play
the final psl
one cologne no one would have said it
but they didn't just make it to the
finals
they made a statement by dominating
vitality oh no
to the lion's den and boris
quad kill for grand final point for the
trophy
this is the first cologne for bob kadian
texas and they're the last team standing
unbelievable
absolutely incomprehendable
but in the midst of one of the greatest
moments of kaden's career
controversy struck
see a spectator bug was revealed that
let coaches cheat
giving them extra information not
normally available to them and among the
list of coaches receiving bans for their
use of this bug
was heroics coach hunden suddenly
heroic's cologne win
was overshadowed by this ban and rather
than
celebrate the team and kadian's
achievement
fans now questioned its legitimacy if
heroic wanted to prove they were legit
they'd need to win another big
tournament and at dreamhack open
fall they did just that could get as
[ __ ]
finally spinning trades but it's too
little too late
tanian is killing it right now remember
it was
ramp that robbed around for the favor of
big one
not long ago four kills and the ace
tess s easy anti-ego he could come and
deny the bomb plan he's a little bit too
late but still takes the head
off of both hampers res and now plovsky
bar up feeling it
they need a player to really step up and
barb's gone in for four
a perfect retake for up take a bow that
was
beautiful to watch heroic face the
hardest path of the tournament
falling straight into the losers bracket
after placing
third in their group but they fought
their way through north
big nip and astralis on route to the
grand finals
where once again they found themselves
facing vitality
and once again heroic denied the french
giants a trophy
test that's up close double headshot
with the glock very good
oh baby a third a fourth and on for the
ace tessas kicks it off
see the car crash coming i see it oh
canadian underpass push
shots is gonna run out from palace finds
a player completely blind in the form of
nico canadians getting covered
4k apex with only 14 hp
1v3 and get ready for acadian pop off
because he's
done it he closes and leads his team to
yet another win
wow heroic stunning
fashion all the way back through the
lower bracket
you cannot question their resilience you
cannot
question their skill or leadership
this is something magical in the making
and the star of the finals was none
other than the team's igl
cadian kaden holy
man he did not skip a beat just
through and through any time when the
pressure is at its highest when he's
faced up against the best
when he's faced up against astralis he's
putting up
just astronomical numbers after spending
the better part of a decade overcoming
every challenge thrown his way kadian
finally found himself at the top of the
counter-strike mountain
and it was a view he appreciated even
more because of the treacherous climb
it took to get there the support from
you fans
it's absolutely insane on instagram and
twitter and all the social media thank
you so much
for sticking with the team for sticking
with me through the rough times it's
been a long path for me to
make a title contention and i played for
so many years without winning anything
and finally it's paying off so thank you
for sticking through with me
and thank you for giving so much i'll
try to give it back
[Music]
you